- [Instructor] What we have here
are pictures of running pigs,
and we can try to figure out
how many running pigs there are
by just counting the pigs,
but we're gonna start
building some new muscles
and this muscle's going to involve,
hey, if we group the pigs
into equal groupings,
can that help us figure out
how many pigs there are?
And you can see that I
have groupings of seven.
Each of these groups
are seven running pigs,
so how many total groups do I have?
Well, I have one, two, three groups
of seven running pigs each.
Three equal groups.
If I said, what's the total
number of running pigs
that I'm dealing with?
Well, I have three sevens,
three groups of seven, and so,
that's the same thing as
seven plus seven plus seven,
and if you wanted to
figure out what that is,
you could skip count.
If we skip count by seven,
we go seven then 14 then 21,
and so, three sevens, which is
seven plus seven plus seven,
is 21, so there's 21 pigs here,
and you can verify on your own
that if you count this, you
will indeed see 21 pigs.
Let's do another example.
Here, I'm looking at a picture
of a bunch of blue seals,
not something that you are
likely to see in the wild.
And these blue seals have,
once again, been grouped.
Let's see how many groups there are.
There are one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven groups,
and how many are in each group?
Well, we could see that
they're all groups of
one, two, three, four, five.
They're equal groups.
What are dealing with?
Well, we're dealing with
seven groups of five,
so I could write seven groups of five.
I could write seven fives.
I could write five plus
five plus five plus five
plus five plus five plus five,
so that is seven fives there.
And if I wanted to
figure out where that is,
I could skip count.
I could skip count seven fives,
so that'd be five, 10, 15, 20, 25, 30, 35.
If I were to add all these fives up,
five plus five is 10, add
another five, you get to 15.
Add another five, 20.
Add another five, 25.
Add another five, 30.
Add another five, 35, which
is exactly what you see there.
We're starting to see that
sometimes grouping things
can help us appreciate how
many things there are there.
And I know what some of
you all are thinking,
well, hey, couldn't I just count things?
Well, you could,
but what if you had 100 groups of five?
Well then, it's gonna take you
a little bit more time to count.
But the techniques that we're building
will help you one day be able to
think about those things quite easily.